well they're also worries about the
effect of diesel engines on the
environment conservative Julie Gerling
is a lead MEP on legislation currently
going through the European Parliament on
air quality very good morning to you
first you can I was getting your
reaction to the fact that we now know
that manipulation also took place here
in Europe yeah that's really
disappointing you know as obvious today
that hadn't been confirmed it's very
disappointing that Volkswagen have
confirmed that today I'm obviously like
everybody else waiting to understand the
the full ramifications of that it's good
that we've had some denials of
manipulation from other manufacturers
particularly here in the UK Jaguar Land
Rover Honda I'm delighted that they're
saying that they have not been part of
this but for the 20% of my constituents
who who are driving around in a
Volkswagen Audi or or ascator it's it's
a it's a huge worry and I'm already
getting emails and you're looking at
because I look at this from the air
quality point of view sorry you're
looking at legislation at this moment in
time tell us about the legislation that
you think needs to be brought in I mean
for example the way that tests take
place in America are very different to
the way that tests take place in Europe
so is there a call now for a more
unified approach well indeed we've in my
report which I wrote about six months
ago and which is before Parliament and
being looked at by the member states to
go into legislation I said that unless
we made significant improve improvement
sin the way in which we can do the
testing here in Europe in other words to
make sure that when people are actually
driving their cars they are getting the
savings on NOx and other emissions that
they're promised unless we do that then
we will have to go to a more us-style
system it does approval testing but then
it has random of takes takes cars off
the road and tests them on a random
basis and
that's when they that's what keeps the
manufacturers honest frankly because if
they only have to go through one type
approval as they do at the moment in
Europe once they've got that certificate
then that's it
and clearly we we know we already have
and have had for a long time the
statistics that tell us that the real
driving conditions do not conform with
those test conditions we are getting an
idea now that this manipulation had been
going on for some time why do you think
it's only coming to light now
well it isn't only coming to light now
in the European Parliament we've been
talking about this for two years at
least we've had two debates in the last
three months in the committee that I sit
in and as I say the report that I've
written could shows it absolutely and
highlights it so there's an issue here
about when media never listen to the
European Parliament perhaps they should
a bit more just thought I'd get that one
in but it is not it isn't that new and
it isn't that big a surprise obviously
the level of fraud this issue of defeat
devices that's new and that has got to
be dealt with as as possibly as it as a
criminal issue but but the the ongoing
problem with the we are de that that's
the real driving tests it's been around
a long time and we've known about it for
a long time
VW employs some in the region of 600,000
people I guess you have to draw a fine
line between the company paying out the
compensation which it will need to do
and also making sure that those who are
on the ground those who are on the
workshop in the factories aren't going
to be affected by this of course I mean
it's it's so big as you said 20 percent
of the market large huge tens and
thousands hundreds of thousands of
people working for VW it's almost the
sort of Bank thing isn't it too big to
fail I think we have to make sure that
we don't demonize to the point where
people's cars become worthless and the
company collapses I think it my personal
view is of course they can recover this
but it's an incredible body blow to
their brand and I wouldn't blame anybody
for thinking twice when
making those those choices when they buy
cars so let's make sure that we can
recover the situation from this and I
know that the government's working very
hard to make sure that we we get in
place as soon as we can as soon as we
know what what the real damage could be
for motorists we get in place systems
whereby they can be compensated okay
Julie girl in MEP interesting talking to
you this morning